ja liebe Nina meine Frage an dich ist
wie war dein Leben in der DDR das Leben
in der DDR
war sehr sehr
solidarisch große große wunderbare
Freundschaften da war ein Zusammenhalt
mit den Leuten gab ja noch kein Internet
und so ein Zeug wir haben uns heimlich
die Musik aus dem Westen auf Kassetten
überspielt wir haben uns gefreut wie
Bolle wenn man jemanden Spiegel oder ein
Stern aus dem Westen mitgebracht hat
Fokus gab es damals noch nicht
und oder wenens eine Bravo und so
und wir haben immer gerne Westfernsehen
geguckt obwohl es verboten war viele
Leute haben sich gegenseitig verpetzt
das war ganz
mies aber die Leute haben so
zusammengehalten und die Liebe hat
gesiegt und die Leute egal ob Christen
oder Atheisten haben sich dann am Ende
jahrelang in den Kirchen getroffen da
hat die staatskrakeen nicht rein da war
die staatskrakeen nicht lange noch und
in den Kirchen haben sie dann dort ihre
verbotenen Witze gerissen ihre
verbotenen Pläne geschmiedet nämlich wie
man in die Freiheit kommt ohne ohne das
was kaputt geht und dann haben sie die
friedlichste Revolution der Welt auf die
auf die Beine gestellt das war 1989 am 9
November viel die Berliner Mauer und war
weil die Menschen in der DDR geschafft
haben sich so wahnsinnig treu zu sein
und so zusammen zu halten und und das
friedlich über die Bühne zu ziehen das
ist der Wahnsinn Leute das müssen wir
noch mal
machen